[Musik]
liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen ein
kurzes statement des ministerpräsidenten
thomas kämmer richter nach kurzer zeit
für fragen und antworten spricht
ministerpräsident thomas kemmerich
schönen guten tag liebe kollegen meine
damen und herren zusammen mit meinen
kollegen der landtagsfraktion der freien
demokraten haben wir beschlossen die
auflösung des thüringer landtages zu
beantragen
damit möchten wir neuwahlen herbeiführen
um damit den makel der unterstützung
durch die afc vom amt des
ministerpräsidenten zu nehmen
demokraten brauchen demokratische
mehrheiten wie sich offensichtlich in
diesem parlament nicht herstellen lassen
die freien demokraten werden weiter für
einen politikwechsel kämpfen und gegen
extreme von rechts und links eine
zusammenarbeit mit der ard gab es nicht
gibt es nicht und wird es nicht geben